Oh, snap.
It looks like Iron Man will be chasing a little
golden man after all.
Just a month after Disney bosses felt the
wrath of Iron Man fans for not including actor
Robert Downey Jr. as part of Avengers: Endgame's
Oscars campaign, the Mouse House has officially
changed course.
Disney, which owns Marvel Studios, has now
updated Endgame's "for your consideration"
page to include Downey Jr.'s name in the Best
Supporting Actor category.
But that's not all.
The Iron Man actor is actually joined in that
category by a veritable who's who of Marvel
Cinematic Universe stalwarts - including Chris
Evans, Mark Ruffalo, Chris Hemsworth, Jeremy
Renner, Don Cheadle, Josh Brolin and Paul
Rudd on the actor side.
Disney is also now pushing Scarlett Johansson,
Gwyneth Paltrow, Zoe Saldana, Karen Gillan
and Brie Larson in the Best Supporting Actress
race.
That's so many actors, it kind of makes you
feel bad for the people who got left out.
This news comes after what's been a surprisingly
tumultuous month for Disney with regards to
Avengers: Endgame's Academy Awards campaign.
MCU fans reacted with shock that the company
had initially chosen not to push Robert Downey
Jr. - whom many believed was more than deserving
of an Oscars nomination - or any of the Endgame
cast in the chase for awards season glory.
That decision was even more surprising given
that Disney's original "for your consideration"
announcement for Endgame included planned
campaigns for Best Picture and Best Director,
not to mention virtually every technical category.
It now appears that Disney brass may have
simply been figuring out the logistics of
which actors to slot into what category for
Downey Jr. and his MCU teammates.
Fittingly, RDJ will now stand alongside his
fellow Avengers as they attempt to charge
the Oscars and net the MCU its first acting
statue.
Though an Oscar win is far from guaranteed
for any of the Avengers: Endgame cast, Downey
Jr. in particular seems to have the odds in
his favor.
After all, Downey Jr. is seen by most Marvel
fans as the founding father of Disney and
Marvel's superhero franchise machine, with
2008's Iron Man marking the film that blasted
the MCU into action.
The years since have seen RDJ appear as the
brash-but-brilliant billionaire Tony Stark
in nine more Marvel films - including his
uncredited cameo in The Incredible Hulk - and
that continued presence essentially made Downey
Jr. the face of the MCU over its first three
phases.
"You know, I hate to say 'I told you so,'
General, but that super soldier program was
put on ice for a reason.
I've always felt that hardware was much more
reliable."
With the actor's time in the MCU officially
at an end after his tearful Avengers: Endgame
goodbye, any awards season love for Downey
Jr. would be the culmination of over a decade's
worth of work inhabiting what has more often
than not been the MCU's most complex character.
But while Iron Man fans will almost certainly
be over the moon that Downey Jr. may have
a chance to take a bow with a golden statue
in his hand on Hollywood's biggest night,
the man himself may not be quite as excited
at this unexpected turn of events.
After that initial "no Oscar campaign for
RDJ's Iron Man" news broke, the actor used
an appearance on The Howard Stern Show to
address the supposed snub, telling the world
that he wasn't really into an Oscar campaign
for his work in Avengers: Endgame to begin
with.
He explained to Stern:
"There was some talk about it and I said,
'Let's not.'"
Like it or not, Downey Jr.'s iron hat has
officially been tossed into the awards season
ring for what's certain to be an intriguing
supporting actor battle.
But even if it remains unlikely in the grand
scheme that RDJ will take home a statue at
the 2020 Oscars, the idea that his iconic
work as the MCU's top dog hasn't earned him
a spot in the conversation until now is pretty
absurd.
All that being said, if there's a second Avengers:
Endgame actor worthy of generating serious
Oscars buzz, it's Chris Hemsworth.
After toiling away in a pair of underwhelming
Thor movies, the God of Thunder finally found
his mojo in Taika Waititi's Thor: Ragnarok.
But nothing we'd seen of Hemsworth's Thor
could've prepared us for the actor's heart-wrenching
work in Endgame.
"I'm still worthy…"
While RDJ's teaful farewell proved a crowning
achievement of the MCU, watching Hemsworth's
"Fat Thor" work through the emotional carnage
of his once-privileged life was often the
most intriguing element of Endgame.
So yeah, if the Academy is preparing to show
Downey Jr. some love, it'd be nice to see
Hemsworth sharing in that adoration.
For now, we should probably just be happy
that Robert Downey Jr. is officially part
of the awards season chatter.
Here's hoping the Academy loves him 3,000.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.